Something's Coming
Guys, Aliens!
We've been calling them the Dominators
That's not the name of a species that comes in peace.
We must exterminate your kind before the scourge of your planet becomes the scourge of ours.
Dominator ships are coming in worldwide
Barry you can't do this alone
I don't plan to
Ah Oliver, Green Arrow, Dig Spartan, White Canary, Firestorm, The Atom, Heatwave
How did you get the name Heatwave?
Oh, I burned my family alive and I like to light stuff on fire.
That's a colorful backstory...
Oh things just got so much worse
You really did it this time Barry
Y'all call for tech support?
No, No, No, No!
Oh I had enough of this
It's been an honor to know all of you, to fight along side of you. Now it's up to you to keep our home safe.
Have fun storming the castle!
Oh, you're gonna use Princess Bride against me!
Here we go
Best. Teamup. Ever!
Hey Youtubers Happy Thanksgiving so of course
they drop like a whole bunch of new crossover
footage like right after I do a crossover
video but we see them go into the matrix all
kinds of Dominators.
So let's break it down We'll talk about this
and then like tomorrow the release like a
10 minute version of the trailer so it'll
be crazy.
But this is your TV Justice League here and
the storylines that they're doing with the
way the Dominators explained the reason for
their invasion is actually straight out of
that comic book storyline, so the Dominators
learned that in the future, humans will be
a big threat, so they try to pull a preemptive
strike the cool thing here is that Lila and
Argus have known about this for a long time
to post that video with the viral trailer
in it all.
Lincoln at the end of this, but they basically
have footage from back during like World War
II era with the Marine Corps fighting off
Dominators and it looks like they're getting
own like to see Citizen Steel here in his
full comic book costume.
Nonetheless just watching them go crazy on
what looks like is viral footage.
So we might actually visit that moment on
legends of tomorrow like this black-and-white
moment is this same moment here on legends
of tomorrow they've gone back into the past
to see this this looks like the heroes have
been captured because they're all wearing
the same jumpsuits just like they did in the
comics they come near in the trailer their
ships landing all over the earth.
This can be really interesting to see how
they try to explain this after they solve
this problem I'm guessing it'll be a legends
of tomorrow type twist whereby they're able
to solve the problem of the Dominators by
the fourth night but they do it in a way that
allows them to a race all this craziness from
the world's memories because typically things
like this like especially in the comics if
you're not can it carry it forward you have
to find a way to wipe everyone's memories
in the easiest way to do that would be time
travel there so many big blockbuster trailer
lines in this like they pulled a much a dialogue
is just straight out of like some huge $200
million movie you can't do this alone.
I don't intend to if they panned this giant
lineup in the warehouse here if you look at
these boxes the background to their star labs
of equipment.
So whatever they're doing here.
It requires hard-core technology Supergirl
meeting, the team learning everybody's codenames
slightly longer version of that bunny heat
wave moment I burn my family alive and I like
the light things on fire this is actually
really cool Oliver inside the braille room
they just they called the braille room on
the TV show just because the way the walls
look and it does next to say anything.
Specifically, they just made it to look really
really cool but remember that during season
two they lost the use of Gideon or lease.
They didn't use Gideon.
You know for whatever reason, they just can
have access to it.
So they might get that back because it looks
like Barry's learning about the future just
saying oh my God things have gotten so much
worse Oliver at the mercy of the Dominators.
This might have something to do with the arrow
crossover there's been a lot of theories about
how the gonna pull off that alternate reality
episode whether or not it's a matrix situation
which it sounds like it is then you see a
scene like this and it looks like some weird
portal of some sort, so that just like very
arrow centric stuff happening here the hundredth
episode.
This can be so much stuff it's totally so
different from other arrow episodes but is
gonna be a lot of fun so Stephen Amell has
said that they tried to make it feel like
a completely different type of error episode
like the way it starts like the typical opening
they would do you know where he narrates all
that stuff is going to be different, so that
you understand this is like an alternate reality
so it can be a lot of fun to see how that
plays out all the science nerds look like
they play with some Dominators technology
trying to reverse engineer their weapons more
of the team reacting to Supergirl like she
just waved a she's having like the most fun
time ever and everybody else's can barely
believe it like oh my God aliens that shoot
fire out of their eyes, what the hell's going
on big team up moment with the president of
the United States.
So looks like it's gonna be a joint military
operation if there are aliens all over the
earth.
Of course are going to need the government
itself, but the question is is will they actually
spin this into more Justice League stuff in
the future or just a society or whatever they
try to call it, it is a weight above and beyond
the team ups that they've done before so now
were getting to that Hall of Justice organize
Justice League style team up nice Princess
bride joke after this can be a ton of those
in the episode, so be sure to keep your eyes
peeled for movie references something goes
like way above and beyond the comic books,
most of it's gonna be comic book stuff but
anytime Cisco and I like citizen Steel around
it was try to work in movie stuff like this
just a huge action montage of scenes the Dominators
the actual costumes are practical, but there's
a lot of CG which actually looks really good
Oliver ponying the Dominators with their own
weapons this character that Barry is beating
the crap out of here doesn't look like LiveWire,
but it does look like another villain or a
collaborator or a dominated the just made
to look like a person I think is just another
new comic book character but will find out
once they list at the IMDb characters usually
IMDb is unreliable until after the episode
little bit at deathstroke really like the
last 30 seconds of this trailer is just like
nothing you very little dialogue just tens
of millions of dollars and hundreds and hundreds
of man hours that it took them to make all
crammed into like this really small 30 seconds
in this really bad ass fire store moment here.
A lot of you are asked me about this like
it looks like he's trying to transform this
entire ship.
He might just be trying to make it go nuclear
just blow it up like imagine a version of
Superman solar flare.
Just unlocking a really crazy new ability
that he has not done before, and I think you
can expect the same thing from the other big
characters to will price he Barry do some
stuff that we haven't seen them do before
using that's what you save for big episodes
like this like they have some insurmountable
threat the heroes have to of falls in order
to defeat them and the money shot, so a lot
of the Dominators storylines in the comics
were set in outer space or set in the future
like there was the storyline called earth
war there was a lot of Legion of superheroes
stuck with the Dominators faced off against
a lot of United planets of which earth was
part so they might work some Easter eggs for
that into this inlet like I said in previous
videos about the crossover a lot of the story
beats will be self-contained.
But they will be carrying things forward to
like Legion of superheroes is really big new
thing that they haven't done yet but we have
Manel on Supergirl heat along with Supergirl
were big parts of the Legion of superheroes
we might see them eventually pick up and run
with that.
On Supergirl, but I'm not really expecting
them to do a Legion of superheroes TV show
like a spinoff TV show by itself.
I think it be more likely that they would
do like the young justice or a teen Titans
show or even just Titans like another team
up show but said in present day we've only
really seen the Dominators in this trailer
footage so I think what they've done from
the comic book storyline is that they could
gotten rid of a lot of the other races that
were part of that because the Dominators formed
an alliance with a bunch of other races including
the Thanagarians the Daxamites of which Mon-El
is a part now is the Hawkman Hawkgirl stuff
gets in the Thanagar.
So with the just in the name of simplicity
just to keep from getting too insane.
This will mostly just be the Dominators attacking
earth by themselves.
So they have a shout out to the Green Lantern
Corps or The Legion of Superheroes or any
other space-based races in the DC universe.
I'll be sure to add it to my videos to be
so many Easter eggs will be fun to try and
find them all but Supergirl video will post
on Monday Flash on Tuesday Arrow on Wednesday
legends on Thursday.
Just like you would expect be sure to subscribe
to get everything.
So just reminder that most of that Supergirl
episode will be like a standalone story that
like the last little bit like the last 10
minutes or so will be crossover stuff that
will spill into like the full-blown Dominators
storyline sir buddy just let me know like
what your most hype about for the big crossover.
I really feel like just them even trying.
It is such a huge deal that I'm so excited
to see how it all works out it'll be interesting
to see how they try and top that next year.
Like maybe they'll do war world.
So be thinking about other ideas for future
crossovers Mongol or just big villains they
could face in future years.
Now, most forgot his Thanksgiving.
So giveaway time.
Congratulations to this week's giveaway winner
Mr. Bacon 18 you win a $20 Amazon gift card
be sure to private message me on the back
and my channel so I can get your contact details.
I'm even going to start a new round again
so all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video.
You know the drill, so I'll announce the winner
the next time I post a DC video.
While you guys wait for my next video you
can click here for my Marvel vs DC video Kevin
Feige is a huge DC Comics fan and you can
click here for that Funny Spider-Man Homecoming
Tom Holland video thank you so much watching
everybody high five I'll see you guys tonight!